bonsoir messieurs et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france commence
avec vous stéphane wali kot que
pensez-vous de l'extension du pass
sanitaires bonsoir
est-ce qu'on avait vraiment le choix
petit 1 nous sommes pas décisionnaires
on a fait en sorte que ce pas ce soit le
plus acceptable entre guillemets
possible mais c'était ça ou la fermeture
quand on voit l'évolution et la
propagation du virus à la vitesse et
qu'elle y circulent je ne suis même pas
certain qu'avec le passé ni terres mises
en place peut-être même tardivement en
matière notamment de vaccination
j'entends nous échappe à une fermeture
je pense que la fermeture
on va y avoir droit les premiers à
fermer vont être les à mon sens les
discothèques ensuite les bars puis
l'ensemble des secteurs des loisirs ils
restaurent évidemment donc je crains que
la vaccination qui ne s'accélère pas les
mouvements que l'on observe ici et là
l'incompréhension de certains français
quant à la vaccination des comparaisons
qui sont faits notamment avec nos amis
anglais qui a broyé mika fait le choix
de tous libérés c'est vrai mais ils ont
un taux de vaccination qui est bien
supérieur à notre pays à patriotisme
bien plus fort puisque les anglais se
font vacciner massivement
mais le revers de la médaille c'est que
de nombreux salariés chefs d'entreprise
sont eux mêmes contaminées atteint de
l'aco vide ce qui fait que de nombreuses
entreprises maintenant au royaume uni se
retrouve sans salarié donc obligés de
fermer leur entreprise et en france ça
vient nous arriver le premier c'est le
chef philippe etchebest qui a dû fermer
son restaurant et les 2500 réservation
parce que oui de ses salariés étaient
atteints draco vide et tout le reste
était quelques contacts chez elle ça on
a fait de même et j'ai lu ce matin
encore christopher coutanceau à la
rochelle chef trois étoiles a dû fermer
rés
parce que des salariés ce matin la
colline au final le pack sérénité au
pasp sanitaires se bat le débat le débat
je pense que c'est la vaccination elle
doit s'accélérer doit s'intensifier de
façon à ce qu'on ne soit pas confronté
aux situations telles que j'en voulais
l'écrire
thierry palomares est ce que vous êtes
d'accord on n'avait pas le choix avec
l'extension de ce pass sanitaires et
maintenant il faut mettre tout donner
sur le sur la vaccination
je vais paraphraser ce que de dire
monsieur effectivement je pense qu'on
n'avait pas le choix
j'attends mais a contrario c'est certain
nombre président à faire ça en pleine
saison estivale
cantona des centaines de réservation à
l'avance pénaliser encore les même
secteur la restauration le tourisme
c'est très compliqué maintenant je vous
avoue d'avoir d'avoir donc décidé ça
presque à l'honneur minutes
alors oui sur lui fallait accélérer la
vaccination n'a pas le choix mais est-ce
que c'était la bonne méthode je sais pas
j'avoue que je suis pas politicienne je
vais pas dire il faut faire super ça ce
que je sais c'est que là à l'heure
actuelle on a vraiment des gros soucis
de logistique et que je ne sais pas
comment on va finir par gérer parce que
jamais que vous êtes directeur d'un
camping comment est-ce que ça se passe
concrètement chez vous quelles sont les
difficultés que vous rencontrez lorsque
des clients arrivent avec pour contrôler
le pas et sanitaires justement alors
dans l'ensemble sauf quand c'est comme
nos clients ça va ils comprennent mais
en revanche on a quelques altercations
avec des personnes qui souhaitaient la
piscine par exemple ce qu'on à la
piscine camping naturel et donc là ils
comprennent pas dix bennes à payer pour
la piscine on comprend pas donc il faut
bien leur expliquer voilà tout faire
toute une pédagogie et c'est du stress
en permanence et puis moi en fait j'ai
un secrétaire simplement et moi au
bureau et donc toutes les heures il
fallait la piscine savoir qui à la
piscine
est-ce que vous avez droit data piscine
est ce que vous avez brasser les doigts
fins
il faut faire le rôle un peu du policier
vous voyez vos clients à l'entrée du
camping peut contrôler ayant contrôle
nous qui ont l'attrait du camping en
revanche ils peuvent très bien par
exemple vous voyez on au bureau ils
peuvent passer par derrière ils peuvent
passer le portail est ouvert dont on
voit pas h24 qui rentrent qui mentent
pas donc il faut sans cesse en fait à
les voir et puis on a des résidents à
l'année on avait de sacrés c'est dans
l'année qui reçoivent des amis et donc
forcément d'efforts entre midi et deux
la pause déjeuner tout l monsieur vous
avez reçues qui est ce qu'il allait pas
ça dit et enfin voilà le voyez faut
aller chaque fois contre les en
permanence plusieurs fois par jour c'est
très très très compliqué cfm manigold
vous vous êtes restaurateur qu'elles
sont vous les contraintes que vous
rencontrez au quotidien avec le ps
sanitaires c'est dans la majorité des
cas les français et françaises se sont
fait vacciner ou sont en train de se
faire vacciner ce qui est plutôt une
bonne chose avant de contraintes être
honnête c'est pas compliqué il ya juste
à flasher ses roues jeu ça passe pas
assez n apparaissent pas dire si c'est
pas ça la difficulté on a réussi à le
sortir
l'idée qu'on n'était pas la police qu'on
n'avait pas contre l'idée
l'identité des gens que c'était pas
notre sort ça oui maintenant il faut
donner du bon sens au passé me taire je
le voit notamment dans le var où un
couvre-feu été mis en place à 23h ce
couvre-feu au fond il reste dans une
punition collective terki compris celles
et ceux qui sont vaccinés et donc on se
passe à lutter et bien 23h et un
couvre-feu
ça c'est pas normal je crois que c'est
les français et françaises qui ont fait
le choix de sa matinée et les milliards
de personnes sur terre qui ont fait le
choix de de ses racines et c'est
justement pour ne pas subir sept
punition collective pour sortir de cette
sanction collective et au nom de la
liberté celles et ceux qui ne veulent
pas servir demande en france ils ont le
choix
mais ceux qui ont fait le choix de se
faire vacciner je trouve que c'est
parfaitement normal qu'à 23 heures ils
subissent un couvre-feu au fond c'est
pas un bon signal pour inciter les
français les françaises à se faire
vacciner
en tout cas cette attitude n'est pas à
mon sens une bonne décision il faut que
celles et ceux qui sont vaccinées bain
puis se libérer puis sortir tellement
nous levant et il faut qu' il faut que
la promesse soit tenue de cette
possibilité de sortir quoi qu'il en
coûte parce que vous ce que vous
connaissez que finalement ce pass
sanitaire soit arrivé trop tard et qu'
il n'y ait la possibilité que la
quatrième vague soit là et que
finalement tout ferme comme pendant le
confinement mais oui vous savez au mois
de mai 2021 donc il ya quelques mois
nous avons eu deux cas 2 4 e vide dans
un vrai restaurant et j'ai contacté
merci pour dire écoutez moi je changeais
de fermer mon restaurant qu'en est il de
la vaccination et que qu'est ce qui va
en être au mois de septembre lorsque
rappelé fonds de solidarité que
l'entreprise sera fermée même répondu
que la vaccination à l'être je dirais
notre secteur à l'aide prioritaire la
semaine d'après et bien j'ai vu
l'ensemble de mes 100 collaborateurs
pour qu'ils se fassent vacciner ils ont
tous été vaccinés pour échapper
justement à cette à ces cas où
l'entreprise est obligée de fermer parce
que plus de salariés ou parce que trop
de cas compact et c'est donc oui diriger
c'est prévoir je pense que cette
décision elle est venue il fallait la
prendre en tout cas concernant la
vaccination a cité les françaises et les
français à se faire vacciner
je pense qu'elle aime trop tardivement
puisque dès lé mois de mai j'ai pu
convaincre l'ensemble des salariés
simple de toute façon si vous fatiguez
pas vous pourrez à faire cet été
je suis convaincu il ya des mesures qui
vont s'appliquer beaucoup plus fortement
et vous voyez les quand on fait de la
pédagogie et quand on rentre dans le
dialogue
eh bien ça marche
je crois que la contrainte ne fonctionne
pas revanche la pédagogie il faut faire
confiance aux chefs d'entreprise faut
faire confiance à vos franchise
française et vous voyez ça marche donc
il n'y a pas de raison mais on a
commencé trop tard ça c'est clair série
palomares est ce que vous avez vous
aussi demandé à aux salariés d'aller se
faire vacciner parce que faut aussi
rappeler que le pass and i ter s'est pas
seulement la vaccination c'est aussi le
test pcr mais ça rend les choses peut
être beaucoup plus difficile mais ce
monsieur j'ai demandé effectivement ça a
été fait
j'ai pas de souci là-dessus et c'est ce
qu'on a demandé aussi aux clients en
revanche la question que se posent les
clients c'est que pour un trait sur le
camping donc soit les vacciner très bien
pas de souci soit effectivement on
présente donc donc tel tertiaire où un
test chimique datant de moins de 48
heures et déjà ne comprennent pas que
s'ils restent une semaine deux semaines
trois semaines le test un petit génie
coup baissière de vente qu'il faut
rentrer donc à leur arrivée dix bsa pas
deux cent six lycées là c'est compliqué
quand même pour pour voiliers pour
argumenter répondre aux gens parce que
je ne tenterais pas ce qu'ils disent
donc certainement pas parfaitement
raison parce qu en trois semaines quatre
semaines ben voilà on peut être une fois
le test ça pas beaucoup de sens
sincèrement est-ce que vous craignez oui
est ce que vous craignez vous aussi
thierry palomares qu il est finalement
une fermeture si la quatrième vague est
bel et bien l'art et que vos efforts
n'est pas porté de fruits mais vraiment
c'est certain je suis quasi certain de
sap effectivement bien sûr vous savez à
venir on travaille d'arrache-pied
vraiment vraiment de cette saison-là
préparer vraiment en amont pendant des
mois on avait le planning complet moi
j'ai des appels tous les jours deux
personnes qui veulent annuler parce que
parlam tout à l'heure une dame
il était prévu huit personnes donc les
parents les grands-parents les
petits-enfants
les papas ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner pareil je rentre pas là dedans
ils ne veulent pas venir avec un test
pcr bel adam but annulé parce que mes
petits enfants pourront pas être là et
c'est pas un cas isolé je me parle là
merci beaucoup à tous les deux un pour
vos éclairages sur vos situations en
tant que restaurateurs et dans un
camping merci ses fans manigold je
rappelle que vous êtes porte parole du
mouvement en restons ouverts et merci à
vous thierry palomares directeur du
camping du plantaurel